hey my name's Samuel Leeds and in this
video I'm gonna give you exactly what
you need to know to do your first rent
to rent deal rent to rent is when you
control property without owning it and
this is what a lot of very successful
companies do Amazon don't own their
stock Buber don't earn their taxis
Airbnb don't own their hotels but
they're wildly rich because they know
how to control and as a property
entrepreneur you can control property
without owning it and in this video I'm
gonna give you these seven phases but
you should walk through an afternoon in
the right order as well so I'm gonna
give you the seven steps in the correct
order that should really help you secure
your first rent to rent deal number one
is market research before you start
sending out letters speaking to
landlords meeting agents and asking them
if they do corporate let's you want to
have a bit of an idea about whether this
area is a good area or not for what
you're trying to do so market research
what does that mean that means looking
at the supply and the demand
what's the supply and demand you can get
a deal and you can get an agent to say
yes or a landlord to say yes but if the
area's rubbish and if there's no real
demand then it sucks or if there's
demands but there's why more supply then
it's not going to make you any money so
the first thing is do your market
research talk to people like hmm
management companies talk to investors
that are already doing it go on spare
room and have a look at the occupancy
rates and have a look how many rooms are
available how many rooms are want it
speeds are companies like a vivo and
different channel managers for serviced
accommodation if you're wanting to rent
the property out serviced accommodation
through air B&B what's the what's the
market like you're gonna need all this
stuff if you're doing a service
accommodation which is basically almost
like a hotel with no staff go to the
hotels in the area and see what their
occupancy rates are like just walk in
and ask and honestly they'll they'll be
some shocking how much they tell you I
do it all the time I just walk into an
area and I say I say to the customer
service person on the desk you know hey
what's going on if you got any rooms
available tonight and they'll say yes or
no and then I'll say the reason I'm
asking is because I'm not looking for a
room
actually I'm doing some market research
about how popular the hotels are in this
area what you know what what typically
is your occupancy right
when are you busiest it's questions this
is all market research when you know
that that serviced accommodation is
going to work well you know that you're
gonna rent rooms out well and there is a
demand then you can start moving on to
phase two and phase two is what I call
felis what I mean by Felix Feliz is then
when you start putting out feelers to
the local landlords investors to estate
agents asking the question about whether
basically whether they're open to rent
to rent or not and what most people do
is they don't put feelers out they try
and close the deal so they'll be they
Davie do the market research thing I've
got a deal and I've got a deal and deals
in a bad area once you know the areas
good for what you're trying to do put
feelers out so say things like to an
agent hey would you be open to me giving
a guaranteed rent to your landlords and
inventing the property out as a serviced
accommodation or as a corporate letter
or speak to tired
hmm landlords would you be open to the
idea of me giving you a guaranteed rent
and then me running this property as a
hmm myself you know that's called
feelers
would you be open would I use that I use
that line all the time would you be open
if you speak to people and they're like
no I wouldn't be open and everyone's oh
no no no no no and you then I wouldn't
say give up but what I would say is it
might be that in that area people are
quite closed-minded it might be that in
that area there's been a million
motivate idiots running around trying to
do rent to rents and now the agents and
the landlords I just closed minded to it
all so so so that's probably a bad sign
and this does happen in some areas but
if people are saying yeah be open to
that yeah that sounds interesting tell
me more or if the figures are right I
guess so now you're beginning to do well
in Phase two because you've done phase
one which is your market research and
you know the area's good number two you
put feelers out to the agents into the
landlords and people are coming back
people are saying yes they'd be open to
it which means you can move to Phase
three now as a disclaimer if you do
phase two and you
really rubbish and you're saying all the
wrong words then you might think all
this area's closed-minded it's not
closed-minded its closed-minded to you
because you're not very good because you
haven't been trained so make sure that
you possess if you haven't got the
skills you got to be really persistent
so that's really important
rocket research is good just the supply
and demand is showing positive you put
feeders out and people are beginning to
come back and they're interested then
that's when you're going to move to
phase three phase three is when you're
gonna start putting some offers forward
now when you put an offer full would
always do what I call and if would offer
I talked about this in another video you
can check it out in the link above I
talked about negotiations but phase
three you're going to put if would
offers which is if I was to give you
five hundred pounds a month
guaranteed rent and then I would then
rent it out myself would that be
something that you could work with as an
if would offer it's not an here's my
proposal it's if I could offer this on
this basis would that be something that
you could go with if when you start
having people say yes boom shacka you've
completed phase three phase three is
you've now got some really hot leads all
this deals on the table which is when
you're gonna move into phase four phase
four is when you're going to do your due
diligence
now market research and due diligence so
for two different things market research
tends to be if you're looking at the
area as a whole if you're looking at a
patch or strategy as a whole due
diligence is when you're looking in and
you're honing down to a particular
person or particular house once you've
done your market research the area is
generally good you've put feelers out
people are interested you then put
forward some offers some if would offers
and you've had people coming back saying
yes then before you sign on the dotted
line or anything like that you're then
gonna move to phase 4 which is right
this person has said that he's up for me
paying him 500 pound a month and then me
running it as a serviced accommodation
or me them really good HMO I learned in
my due diligence I've got to work out
the legalities I've got to check if it's
an apartment the head least I've got to
make sure what I know that this area
will rent out people do serviced
accommodation rent to service
accommodation without doing due
diligence what happens is they end up
paying someone's
but they can't rent it themselves
they're down each month big problem do
your due diligence make sure that you're
really honing on that particular
property speak to people if it's a
service accommodation speak to a vivo if
it's a hmm speak to different HMO
managers and make sure that you do due
diligence on the property before you can
move on to Phase five phase five is do a
best case worst case breakdown workout
I've done my due diligence I know that
this is good but what is the worst case
what if now be realistic when you do
don't say what if I fall out with the
landlord and then he comes around my
house and kills me and my children
because that's just that's just
ridiculous you know or what if I do this
and then my parents don't like that I'm
successful and then and then they fall
out with me like what's the worst case
that could happen on this deal
financially that could hurt me what's
the worst case look at the worst case
and then you just got to protect
yourself if the worst case is that the
worst case is that I will not be able to
rent it out then put in a break clause
in the agreement where you say look
after three months or six months mr.
landlord if I miscalculated this
property and it's not renting out and
this doesn't work at all as HMO I'd like
the opportunity to be able to give you
the keys back
they'll be understanding of that if
you've been up front from the first
place and said you wonder when it's a
HMO off them all I find is because they
want they guaranteed rent they go yeah
it would definitely work with HMO and
they sell me on the idea
they sell me they're the one that wants
to rent the house out there the what the
one's guaranteed rent don't feel like
you're the dirty little person coming
along trying to do something conniving
no you're offering a great service so
the landlord will often say to you yeah
work and then you can say look I know
you've said it will work I've spoke to
different people who said it's gonna
work but if for ever reason and I've
miscalculated something and this
particular property just doesn't work I
just want to break claws just to make
sure that I'm not and then after three
months or six months after the break
doors is done then for the rest of the
term however long will turn might be
three years five years you get you
guaranteed rent the worst case might be
something different the worst case might
be that you are dealing with a landlord
who's doing something illegal and you
getting wrapped up in that case protect
yourself get a solicitor bring a
solicitor involved and just say look you
know can you check over the legals
whatever the worst case is whatever the
biggest threat is that could potentially
hurt you you want to get that covered
there's always in business going to be
risk the definition of an entrepreneur
is someone that takes risks but you
really want to prevent anything from
happening that could harm you and you
want it you want to protect yourself so
best case worst case so market research
the area put some feelers out to the
agents and the landlords then put some
if would offers and get some offers in
principle then do you do diligence hone
in on that particular house holding on
that particular landlord make sure
everything it's all good next number
five best case worst case best its
commit optimist right you want to be an
optimist you want to be able to look
look this is the best case but at the
same time as a businessman you've got to
be negative sometimes you look at the
worst case protect yourself put break
clauses implies to recover the worst
case number six once you've done these
five things is you want to put the
paperwork together get the contracts
ready now if you're doing a rent to rent
you need a special contract you don't
just rent it off the landlord on a
normal AST and then put someone else in
on an AST that's called subletting which
is actually illegal seems to make sure
it's done with a management agreement
and you can you can purchase these or
you can get a solicitor to draw them up
or if you're one of my students or
certainly one of my advanced students
you have all these sort of stuff given
to you but make sure that you have the
right contract in place once you've done
that number seven which is what that's
when the work begins roll your sleeves
up and start managing that property and
make it the best property you can now
what I often say to guys is rent to rent
is usually it can be but it is usually
not passive income rent - rent can be
massive income but not normally passive
income now there's always an exception
to the rule if you get set it up with
really good power teams in place and a
really good management company in place
but what I would say is when you're
starting out if went to rent it's a
great strategy if you've got no money
but if you've got no money and you've
got no time and you've got no income to
work then being financially free and
property he's going to be seriously hard
if you've got no money but you've got
the inclination and you've got the time
to put in then you can do this and at
that point number
there's go to work make it the best
running property in the game get some
experience ready for your next property
where you can buy it using someone
else's money or you can raise the
finance whatever it all save the money
off the rent to rent but be prepared to
work the people that make it do rent to
rents are always the people that
prepared to work don't get me wrong if
you want a passive income and you've got
money in the account you can you can do
that but starting with no money at all
and not having time and wanting to pay a
deal source of three thousand pounds to
give you a rent to rent that's going to
make a grand a month it's just not
realistic it's just not going to happen
and by the way now there's some very
good deal sources out there but I
personally would not pay for a deal and
I wouldn't pay for a rent to rent deal
because I've gone out we have a property
investors Academy of all my advanced
students and at the end of the
graduation I say raise your hand if
you're financially for it by the way
eighty six percent eighty six percent
success result we have with the Academy
which is really high by the way there's
other people have done deals then we do
this thing where we say what's been the
biggest mistakes what's been the biggest
lessons I've been the biggest amount of
money that you've lost and we go around
every single time people's biggest
mistake is paying deal sources for
rental rents so I'm not saying don't do
that but be super careful my opinion is
if you're going to do a renter rent do
it yourself to get the learning off it
and the money but don't expect it to be
passive and don't expect it to be easy
it is very doable you can get high cash
flow you can retire offers let those
three or four rental rent deals but just
be prepared to work I know you are
because you got to the end of this video
so you've paid to put the time in so
congratulations for that if you found
this video helpful please share it also
I do a video every single day and the
reason I keep doing more videos is
because I know that people are watching
them and I know that people benefit from
them so if you benefited please do let
me know just drop a comment below and
subscribe I'm trying to get hit my
subscribers to one hundred thousand when
that happens I'm gonna start doing some
crazy stuff so thanks so much and I look
forward to seeing you tomorrow on the
next video
you